amican universities in particular that
have gotten in the habit over the course
of the last five years of commenting on
anything that's happening in the world
of condemning anything that they dislike
suddenly for conspicuously silent uh
when the worst massacre of Jews since
the Holocaust took place um and then
when these institutions uh were forced
by public pressure to make statements
about this as they have about everything
else there was a huge counter reaction I
mean hundreds and thousands of um uh
students in and and faculty members
fting the university for speaking out in
this kind of way um and uh I feel that
as the the conflict in the Middle East
looks Set uh to escalate um uh that uh
war on campus and in many other
institutions is going to escalate as
well